get into the mind of the marker now i'm
trying to get this perspective shift
for you okay i feel very fortunate in
some ways
becoming a math teacher has actually
made me a better maths
student if that makes sense which is by
the way one of the reasons why
if you want to study i should have said
this on the first hitting one of the big
tips for you guys
is to explain stuff to each other get in
a study group right get three or four or
five of you close friends about the same
ability
and don't just do questions right stand
up
and explain okay guys this is this is
the question and this is why this is the
answer to that
okay and this is this is why einstein
said one of his famous quotes
that you do not understand something
until you can explain it simply okay so
push yourself to do that now i'm trying
to i'm trying to get you to do that i'm
trying to
push you out of your student head and
into a marker's head
right have a look at this question you
could do this what topic is this
this is this is coordinate geometry
isn't it okay um you have to calculate a
gradient
and then you have to write down the
equation of this this straight line
okay now here's what i want to get to
see these numbers over here there's two
and this one what do they mean
yeah that's right now
you've got two marks a part a one mark
for part b
okay now when i was a student i went
through and i basically ignored these
okay you know when you thought about oh
important details to the question
it's all over here isn't it and up here
this is just that's for the teachers
isn't it no it's not okay well i mean it
is but it's also for you we put that
information on there very deliberately
okay what should you be thinking
well at the very least you can think
okay i think this question is harder
than this question
right more marks more work more
difficulty okay
but there's more here than that okay let
me show you
these are marking guidelines okay us
mathematicians
we have to produce this every time you
guys do an exam okay
we have to make one of these in order to
be able to mark you consistently
because we can't be able to say oh you
know you've got a variety of people
and maybe they don't all have the right
answer but they're wrong in different
ways
right now if you're wrong in different
ways it's like well
some of you deserve marks some of you
don't some deserve more and some deserve
less
so we need some kind of consistent
standard that's going to be able to help
us
judge kind of like a set of laws if you
like
um what kind of mark should someone be
awarded right so have a look here
those two marks right they were just
kind of like oh i don't know it's kind
of hard
so i'll put two marks on it rather than
one those two marks
are for two specific elements okay
here's the first mark formula it's a
gradient
isn't it so you can see the formulas
here right but just writing down the
formula on its own doesn't get anything
okay it's formula and substitute so what
i'm looking for as a markup
is this line here see that six minus two
on zero minus five now
i see that not only do they know the
gradient formula but they know how to
use it
right so that's what this stands for the
second mark of course is for
the gradient which is what was being
asked for okay but do you notice
right what would happen what would
happen if
someone just wrote down rather than all
of this they just wrote down
negative four fifths according to the
marking guidelines what would they get
they'll just get one because this piece
which i'm looking for
it demonstrates understanding it's
missing
okay so when you see a question and it's
got two months or three or four
right you need to think to yourself now
what are they actually looking for
right people often say oh maths
some particular kinds of teachers of
other subjects will often say this more
than others but they say
you math teachers have it so easy just
right or wrong it's just ticking right
it's very very simple
but i hope you can see it's more complex
than that right we're actually looking
for
steps and for stages and trying to
interpret how well does someone
understand what's going on
okay